welcome back to age 701
so we start a new chapter now qcd or
quantum chromodynamics
and in this first lecture of this
chapter we talk about the production of
headphones
um this is really meant as an
introductory lecture but we will also
already see some very
interesting and useful concepts
so we want to produce quarks and
antiquark pairs
um and we do this in electron position
collisions
we have studied in detail this first
part of the diagram already
um specifically we calculated the
cross-section of electron
of muon and anti-mu and production and
we also have seen
what changes then we have same same
particle in the final state so the you
know electron positrons scattering to
electron positrons
so now we will place the muons with our
quarks and antiquark pairs
and it's as the first step we want to
remind ourselves of the available quarks
in this discussion
so we have the up quark the down clock
charm strange top and bottom
you see that the charges are given here
and the photon couples to the charge so
the charge
is not one but it's either two thirds or
minus one third
um we are also here in this table mass
is given for those particles
they range from a few mev to 173
gv for the top quark um the bottom quark
is about 5 gb heavy
um remember when we discuss um discussed
renovation we discussed that those
masses are not fixed parameters but in
our perturbation series they run
like the couplings one so this might
cause
some difficulties later on okay
so now we want to produce an up quark
and an anti-up quark in this collisions
what happens
so in our collisions then you know we
produce those quad particles so let's
say there's an up quark and then anti up
here and then the plus the minus
collision
um those quarks only live for a very
short
time of travel a very short distance in
space about 10 to the minus 15 meters
and then they start to pull in out of
the vacuum
um gluons and quarks and anti-pairs and
those
then form um into the actual heart runs
after some time
and those two pictures here they look
very much the same um the difference is
the way
we treat the hydronization the actual
fact of forming hardrons
in this first picture we are thinking
about clustering
energy particles together in that
waveform heart ones
in this picture here we connect them
with so-called strings
and those are two different ways to
model and and model
the production of headphones remember
when we look at this process here we are
looking at
very low energy kind of or lower energy
kind of
phenomena and at lower energies the
strength of the
strength of the strong interaction the
strength of q3d
is the coupling is in the order of one
or can be larger than one so
perturbation theory is not positive
that's why we need specific models
this is all i want to say at this point
we come back to this discussion later on
what i actually want to discuss is you
know what we can learn out of
measuring cross-section of heart run
production
um for example by comparing directly the
cross-section
of of quark and the cochlear production
with the cross-section
we just calculated for human
anti-virulent production
and experimental results are given here
so you see as a function of energy
here from one gev to a 7gb center of
mass energy and then the lower plot
just continuing from about 10 to 60 gb
what you see here is that there's a rich
structure um so you see those resonance
here and you also see that there seem to
be some
sort of increase in this in the value of
this ratio
so how can we now understand this at
leading order
we can just write this down we just
calculated the cross section for
electron
uh neuron scattering or for electron
neuron production um and we can
write this very same cross section in
leading order for
quark anti-clock production what we find
as differences
is the coupling the coupling itself here
we have to use the charge of the
quarks and not the charge of the
electron so there's an additional factor
here
one third or two thirds squared and then
there's
the number of possible quark pairs which
are available and that depends on the
number of colors
remember each quark appears with three
different colors so we have to account
for this vector
all right and then we build the ratio
and the ratio everything just cancels
out
great um so we have just the number of
colors times the sum
of the charges squares of the quarks
available
what do i mean by the quarks available
as we go from
from lower energies to higher energies
in this plot here
the kinematic the the energy is
sufficient to produce particles based on
the masses available so we find that
this explains the step function let's
look at a specific example
so if we look at center of mass energies
which are larger than two times the mass
of the bottom quark
and maybe lower than two times the mass
of the top quark we are in this specific
regime here
and you see this is almost flat and the
number we get is almost four
okay what we get from this
leading order calculation is three times
four over nine for our up quark
uh one over nine four down one over nine
for charm
strange four over nine for charm and one
over nine
for our bottom quark okay so we built
the sum here
for all quarks which are kinematically
available and as an answer
we get 11 over three
so this is in very good agreement
at leading order and very good equipment
with experimental results
11 over 3 is almost 4.
excellent so this is clear indication
experimental indication that
you know this color factor here is a
real thing
you know there seem to be three up
quarks three down clocks with shampoos
and so on
um and we also see that this leading
order effect here the leading order
calculation is already very precise
and the reason for this is that this
process here
is the qed process so the the production
cross section is a qd process if it does
discuss
so now why do i actually have this as
part of our qcd introduction
first we learned about the color factor
here
okay and second there is indeed
corrections
and one of the correction is the one
where you actually produce
a real gluon in the final state and
those corrections
can be calculated um if you go to higher
order you get a correction
from this which from this from this
radiated gluon
you also get corrections which look like
this vertex corrections and you find
that
the correction here to r is about
one plus alpha s at a specific scale
over pi
now at a reasonable scale this is then
you know
about 0.1 is the value of alpha s and
pi is 3.14 and so you get about
a few percent three percent correction
to the r value
great why is this so important when
there's a small correction it's a
percent or few percent level correction
what is really important is that this
processing
can be used in order to um demonstrate
the existence of gluons and so clones
have been discovered this way and
the way this was done is you know by
producing the plus and minus
collisions and detecting three bunches
of particles
two from the quarks and one from the
plums
and then to identify that this gluon
here is actually a gluon
and not some other particle one can look
at angular distributions one can
identify that this is been one particle
and so on so there's a little bit more
work needed beyond just showing that
there's rejects
but identifying this kind of topology in
e plus a minus collision led to the
discovery of gluons
in this kind of collisions so that was
my introduction as a next step we now
want to
have one more step of
now how can we learn about this kind of
structures before we then
dive into primary diagrams or farming
calculations farming rules
you